[Music]
hi
i'm catherine adamcic and since 2014
i've been responsible for developing
education programs at the world chess
hall of fame
recently we have offered
adult hands-on art workshops and
book discussion groups and
now we're having to do that online in
response
to covet 19 and
all that's been happening in the
community
that's just a little bit of information
for you to understand what i'm going to
show you
we are making our own chess set and it
will be a fiber art project
all of our adult programs are based on
the
exhibitions at the hall of fame and
uh take an interesting spin on
interpreting the
stories behind the objects in the
exhibition
the funding from strategy across the
boards
gala will help us to continue to work
with artists and
educators and the people who help us to
bring
all the variety of programs that we
offer for adults and those
include book groups and discussions and
artist talks studio visits hands-on
workshops
and the funding will help us to make
those a reality
in normal times we're meeting often with
local artists
and community groups to collaborate on
our programs
that's changed now and we're doing that
online
instead but it's a big part of our
mission to reach out and to work with
the artists
in our community and also with community
groups and other arts organizations too
we work with local artists regional
artists um
and other workshop providers
to build relationships in the community
we do that on a pretty regular basis and
the number of people we work with has
been growing steadily
i hope you'll consider funding adult
programs
you can do that by contacting
worldchesshof.org
and making a contribution or by hitting
the donate button on your screen